>> MY ONLY ISSUE IS IF THAT WAS
TRUE AND THE POLICE WERE SCARED.
THEY HAVE THE GUNS AND WEAPONS.
THEY HAVE EVERYTHING TON BE
SCARED, RIGHT.
EVEN IF THEY WERE SCARED OF US
WHY IS THAT OKAY TO SAY I'M NOT
DOING THAT.
THEY TRASHED A BIRD DOG --
>> LARRY: TALKING ABOUT THE
GUY IN AFGHANISTAN
>> THEY SAID HE DIDN'T DO HIS
JOB BECAUSE HE WAS AFRAID OR HAD
A -- THEY SAY HE WAS A COWARD.
WHY IS IT OKAY FOR POLICE TO SAY
WE'RE SCARED, SO WE'RE NOT DOING
OUR JOB.
THAT'S OKAY?
THERE JOB IS TO DO THIS.
>> LARRY: I AGREE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT'S DEFENDED
SO VIGOROUSLY WHY FOX NEWS HAS
THE GLEE ON THEIR FACES ?
>> YES YOU DO.
LARRY: BLACK PEOPLE --
I DO, I HATE THAT I DO.
>> I THINK IT'S TIME FOR THE
WIRE 2.
[LAUGHING]
>> LARRY: A NEW TV SHOW.
>> A NEW WIRE.
LARRY: THAT WILL SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
BALTIMORE IS YEARNING FOR IT
ANOTHER BLEAK DEPICTION.
>> I DON'T THINK WHITE LIBERALS
HAVE HAD ENOUGH TIME TO
ROMANTICIZE BLACK STRUGGLE IN
BALTIMORE.
GET TO THE WIRE.
PROVE IT.
>> LARRY: THE REASON I BROUGHT
UP THE BLACK/BLUE THING.
THERE ARE A LOT OF BLACK PEOPLE
IN CHARGE IN BALTIMORE.
BLACK MAYOR -- COPS.
WHY IS IT GETTING WORST?
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT RACE AT THAT
LEVEL.
WE NEED A STRUCTURAL ANALYSIS
TOO. WE DIDN'T MARCH TO
INTEGRATE POLICE FORCES FOR
BLACK COPS TO BEAT US.
WE DIDN'T INTEGRATE SCHOOLS FOR
BLACK TEACHERS TO FAIL US.
WE NEED A DIFFERENT MENTALITY.
THE POLICE HAVE A
PARTICULAR IDEOGOLGY ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANS TO POLICE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THE MAYOR AND THE GOVERNOR AND
THE PRESIDENT.
>> IF THEY HAVE THE SAME
IDEOLOGY OF THE PREDECESSOR IT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE GAME.
>> LARRY: YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT HAS THIS IDEOLOGY.
>> I'M JUST SPEAKING IN GENERAL
TERMS. I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
I THINK HE HAS A PARTICULAR
STANCE ON POLICING THAN I
DON'T AGREE WITH
>> LARRY: WHAT IS THAT?
>> THE PRESIDENT, WHEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS HE SAID "I UNDERSTAND
WHY EVERYONE IS MAD."
[LAUGHING]
>> SOUNDS LIKE YOU, MAN.
>> THAT'S MY GENERIC WHITE GUY
IMPERSONATION
>> LARRY: OBAMA IS HALF WHITE--
>> A HALFRICAN.
HE SAID I UNDERSTAND WHY BLACK
PEOPLE ARE MAD AND WHITE PEOPLE
ARE MAD.
I UNDERSTAND WHY --
>> LARRY: HE'S HAS TO BE THE
PRESIDENT TO EVERYONE.
>> THAT'S STUPID.
[LAUGHING]
>> HEAR ME OUT.
HEAR ME OUT.
>> IF OBAMA CAME OUT AND SAID
-[BEEP] YOU, I'M JUST THE
PRESIDENT OF BLACK AMERICA.
THAT'S IT AND DROP THE MIKE.
>> HE'D HAVE MY VOTE.
I'M NOT ASKING HIM TO IDENTIFY
ONE GROUP OR THE OTHER.
CHOOSE THE OPPRESSED OVER THE
OPPRESSOR. THAT'D BE LIKE IN
1865 SAYING " -- SLAVES
ARE MAD, MASTERS ARE MAD.
I UNDERSTAND."
>> I THINK THEY DID SAY THAT.
I THINK THEY DID SAY THAT.